- [Narrator] The largest
monument in Europe
is located in Leipzig, Germany,
and was built on the location
Napoleon surrendered.
Completed in 1913,
the Monument to the Battle of the Nations
is named after the battle that took place
100 years earlier,
between Napoleon and his allies
and the United Armed
Forces of Russia, Prussia,
Austria and Sweden.
The fight involved around 600,000 troops
from over 20 countries,
and was the largest
European battle prior to World War I.
At the base of the monument
is the Archangel Michael.
Above him are giant stone
guards who circle the structure.
Inside the ground floor,
there are eight knight statues
who represent the fallen soldiers.
They are joined by other smaller figures
known as the Guardians of the Dead.
These guardians watch over all the souls
who have been lost.
All of these statues on the ground floor
are shadowed by the 31-foot
giants on the second story
known as the Hall of Fame.
Each of these represent
the four historic qualities
attributed to the German people:
bravery, faith, sacrifice and fertility.
During the Communist
era, when many monuments
were torn down, this one survived
because the structure commemorates a war
when the Russians and
Germans fought together
against a common enemy.
The scale of the monument inspires awe.
With a height of nearly 300
feet, towering over Leipzig,
and reminding all who view it
of the battles of the past.